christine poirier est candidate libérale
dans laurier 7 ma vie voici son affiche
électorale à dominante de rouge et de
noir maquillages et éclairages soignés
cadrage parfait du travail de
professionnels photo comme ça on a
l'impression que c'est pas tout à fait
soi mais c'est une très belle photo là
j'ai des bons échos
élection après élection les libéraux
fédéraux ont toujours utilisé à peu près
la même facture classique pour leur
affiche au québec comme ailleurs au pays
mais cette année pour la première fois
les libéraux du québec affichent leur
indépendance pour faire une campagne
distincte de ce que ce qui se fait dans
le reste du canada pourquoi parce que
c'est la campagne que non souhaitée et
qu'on est très autonome et les gens
d'ottawa nous font confiance alors on
est si dit que c'était notre campagne on
l'a fait à notre façon c'est une
campagne québécoise par des québécois
pour des québécois
par petits groupes les candidats
libéraux du québec sont allés aux mêmes
studios de montréal se faire
photographier par un photographe aussi
spécialisé dans la mode
ils devaient tous porter du noir la lure
devait être décontracté
tous devaient faire face à la caméra
pour regarder les lecteurs droit dans
les yeux
les montréalais se rappelleront qu'en
2013 la candidate à la mairie mélanie
joly avait été la première à utiliser ce
type d'image très stylisé on voit le
candidat mais où est le chef justin
trudeau
le voici sur des affiches grand format
déployés à quelques endroits
vous trouvez que ça c'est entre
guillemets ça vend bien d'être avec
monsieur trudeau alors ça c'est sûr moi
ya des gens que johnny des personnes
âgées qui viendront pour dire je suis
fia de donner mon appui un monsieur
trudeau et vous même les libéraux du
québec ont donc beaucoup investi dans
l'image qu'est ce que ça vous donne ça
donne centre vue là ça donne quand on en
parle beaucoup s'adonnent que les gens
nous appellent qui nous écrivent ces
différents c'est oser c'est un ris un
risque en voici un les affiches rouge et
noir donne lieu à toutes sortes
d'interprétations gothiques sur internet
on s'amuse ferme ces temps ci sur les
réseaux sociaux
un autre risque des affiches posées si
tôt dans une campagne si longue pourrait
les voir endommagés par le mauvais temps
ou par le vandalisme car la campagne est
longue si longue que le soir du scrutin
la candidate christine poirier aura déjà
accouché depuis un mois et demi ici
maxence bilodeau radio canada montréal